rand  hey rand  what what what i i just had to say that  you're a loser and oh one more thing  i've seen okay ran ran look  it's like fire in my mouth yeah you got  fire in your face it's cool all right it  was scary the first 200 times i saw it i  mean what do you what even is it oh it's  it's a new snapchat filter um but it's  just for dark friends so if you join me  you can get the one of the many perks  right of joining me  uh plus you know preferred parking and  uh we have spot free spa day every every  other friday also i won't kill you i'm  i'm going back to sleep all right i mean  are you sure okay so more psychological  torment tomorrow night yeah  [Music]